[inaudible] joining me today is an
Iranian born Shia Muslim scholar and the
president of the Islamic
Association of South Australia.
You mom Mohammed to Ed. Welcome
to the Rubin report. Hello.
Thank you for having me.
Which one of us is going to be in
more trouble for doing this? Well,
I'm already in enough
trouble, so hopefully we can
share that part. All right,
so two interesting things that happened
even before we start this conversation.
First you said to me in the green room,
nothing is off limits.
You said asked me the hardest questions
you can possibly do because, uh,
I appreciate that as an interviewer and
that's, it's a refreshing thing to hear.
Um, I just thought it was interesting
that you even said that to me because it's
like, you know, a lot of times people just
want to come in and say what they want,
but, but you, you want to be challenged.
You want to go to those places.
I'm trying to,
I've had so many interviews over 400
interviews in the last two years,
whether they be on radio
or television or youtube.
And I just feel that many people,
uh,
give us special treatment just because
I'm Muslim and even though they know that
I do have some conservative views such as,
uh,
a border on border protection,
national security,
but even then they still want to
give me that special treatment.
So I made that request publicly as
well. Yeah. Okay. Please don't be nice.
There's a lot of information
I could share. All right,
well I'm probably going to be nice to you,
but I will try to get to some of the
hard stuff. Don't worry. It's right here.
That's number one. And then number
two, right before we started,
you requested that normally
right behind you there we have a,
a little bing of wine bottles
that are right behind you.
And you asked that we removed it just out
of your direct shot behind you because
you just don't want to get any, any
bonus hate, let's say, which I think is,
I sympathize with that position.
But it's also sort of interesting
because you take all of these very
controversial positions and it's like,
oh,
well they got him with some wine
bottles. It's like, yes, well these, uh,
issues of the extremist agenda,
extremist can obtain an image of me
beside the wine bottle or a bottle for
example.
Then they can easily discredit me as a
Muslim e mom because Muslims don't drink
and I don't drink either.
But they can easily stick that accusation
when they have a picture of me being
close to a wine bottle and they want that
and I'm not going to allow them to do
that. How thrilled are they going to
be that you're in the home studio?
Have a gauge you, this cannot be a, a,
that's got to be worse than wine bottles.
What's the list?
Well,
I would say 2% upset
and they won't be happy.
They won't be happy at the fact that,
uh, you have a large audience as well.
So they try to silence me and you've
got people that tried to silence you as
well. So, but I'm happy to be
here getting on not to do or not.
I'm happy to be here. Yeah. And I'm happy
you're here and all right. So let's,
let's let it fly. So first just tell me
a little bit about your history. You,
you grew up in Iran until you were about
12 years old, right? Correct. Yeah, I was,
uh, in Iran, uh,
for the first 12 years of my life
and we traveled to Australia.
We'll ended in 1995.
My father is a prominent
Muslim faith leader as well.
And your mom and he traveled
from Melbourne, which we,
we first landed to Western Australia
and established the first Shia Muslim
mosque. And it was originally
a church. He called the,
it was called Saint Mary Church,
so he left her name Saint Mary Mosque.
Wow. Yeah. Out of respect for the
Greater Christian majority. Huh. And,
uh, you see my father, I
learned tolerance from him.
He didn't have that belief in him
that, or it's a church, it's filthy.
We can't turn it into a mosque.
It was for sale.
The people will come to the mosque.
Well,
none of these terrorist attacks had
happened. People were fine with mosques.
And so the first mosque was
erected in, uh, uh, in, uh,
Perth, Western Australia. And, uh,
basically I grew up there until 2007
I was raised her amongst scholars and
Islamic teachings and a very
conservative Muslim family.
I come from what is a
conservative Muslim family mean?
A conservative Muslim family,
uh,
goes the extra mile to be extra religious.
So we wouldn't even go to banks or
shopping centers that played music,
let alone listening to music ourselves,
whereby other Muslims would not
listen to music because it's banned in
mainstream Islamic jurisprudence.
Uh,
there would still go to
shopping centers and you know,
at 10 music lessons in class,
in school, but we were very,
very conservative. I couldn't wear
anything shiny or anything like that,
such as watches or Nicholas
or anything like that.
What was that like for you or just
as a young person that, you know,
I'm sure you knew that
music was out there.
I'm sure you knew movies were out there
in video games and the rest of it,
I'd never been to a cinema
until I was 20 years old. Well,
I've never actually completed a
movie. Now I'm not here to, uh, uh,
play the oppressed person in or was harsh.
And I know you are not me,
but I'm going to be,
I try to be as honest as I can.
I didn't know what that life was like.
So the life I was living was very normal.
It was,
this is how life is to me. I didn't know
there was another life. And in fact,
when I first moved to a,
uh,
a public Australian school, uh, I, uh,
was shocked that we actually had people
that were not Muslim because the school
I grew up in was a, I was
raised in initially, uh,
completed my initial studies in
Western Australia. There were,
it was a private Muslim school,
also a conservative atmosphere.
So the house was a
conservative atmosphere.
School was a conservative atmosphere
up until 2007 I had gone back to Iran.
And then you've got sharia law everywhere.
Wow.
So I've never actually had time to be
open to the rest of the world and just
accepted everyone. And that
happened after, you know,
my family was oppressed by Isis in
2014 when I was still there studying.
And it just hit me that this can't
be the way we were supposed to live.
Do you remember the moment
that it hit you? Was it,
was it finally going
because another school? No,
I was an Islamist a fundamentalist
and an extremist as well. Okay.
So I'm going to later in the interview,
let's define some of those terms because
I think people get lost a little bit in
the difference between Islamist
jihadist, fundamentalist, etc. Okay.
So put it this way, I wouldn't
have sat with you. Yeah. Uh,
before 2014 I wouldn't have,
I wouldn't even shake your hand because
that was the mentality that I had
complete rejection of the
west and I was walking in,
in the holy city of Karbala.
It's a Shia Muslim stronghold.
And the speakers of the sacred
shrine of [inaudible] are saying,
and now that Mosul,
which is Mosul,
the Iraqi city close to Baghdad,
had fallen under the authority of Isis.
And that's what an hour away from where
I was. So that's when it really hit me.
And then as I tried to leave the country,
uh,
I found a lot of struggle because
airports went out blocked.
These guys were shooting down airplanes
and the Australian passport that I had
saved me, I was given priority
and I returned back to Australia.
But before all of this happened, my
uncle was kidnapped, burnt, alive,
who served in the Iraq army.
And we had to go receive
his body from Baghdad.
So this whole scenario woke me up.
And when I came to Australia, I saw
that hand got Muslims killing Muslims.
I've been interrogated in Iran for
several times for my views and opinions.
And the Muslims in Australia
are playing the victim card,
recurring Islamophobia.
So then I started to form diplomatic
relations and public relations to combat
extremists. So what was it like
right when you got onto the scene?
Right when you started being
more public about this?
Cause I'll be very honest with you,
when I first saw you on Twitter and you
were tweeting about some of these things,
I thought I can't immediately,
everybody was like, Reuben,
you've got to have the
amount to eating on.
Everybody was saying it and I was like,
this guy just came out of nowhere.
I can't just magically sit down with him.
I am not perfectly versed in
all of these things obviously,
and I don't want to be
used as upon basically.
So what was it like as you started
talking about these things from the inside
community and the outside community?
Okay.
The inside community knew who
I was because of my lineage,
because descend from the,
the companions of the Prophet Mohammed,
one of the early converts from
Christianity to Islam and you know,
shared their wealth and the military
and the tribes and everything.
A military power with
the Prophet Muhammad.
And they went through it with
the Route Arabia in all the wars.
And I've written in my book that they're
terrorists. So my prominent lineage, uh,
my father,
my grandfather,
and also the fact that I was
close to the ground, I told us,
and I was ordained
publicly as like your mom.
So the inside world of Islam knew
who I was and I still had Facebook,
I still had Twitter, you know, very
humble following of basic following.
And, but I was still known not that
being Twitter star you are now. Well,
life changes. Yeah. So
what happened was the,
there was no Naomi and there are many
forums now dating back to 2008 that
discuss what I'm doing. So they
knew who I was. But as you,
as you started speaking up against,
didn't have plans to speak out.
I didn't have plans.
I'm going to be honest with you.
Many people think that I have an agenda.
I didn't have any plans.
I was discovered by,
look how I'm putting it as though,
but American idol, Australian
idol, let's go. Uh,
I got a call from channel
seven in Australia,
one of the Best Australian
that channels top channels.
And they had a program called tonight,
tonight.
And apparently they googled Mrm Adelaide
Muslim, just to get a comment. Yeah.
So they came in wanting a three minute
comment on a certain issue and I gave
them a 30 minute talk about the
Muslim community and everything.
And so they take that and then the
director gets in touch with me and they're
let you know, we can do a lot with
what you're saying and you have this,
we didn't know.
So then I became known in
the area nationally and
then internationally I had a
few heated exchanges on
Australian television.
Sunrise. Yeah. Were those
usually with a suspect?
They were proudly with white people
on the left. Is that fair to say?
Or maybe maybe with people
more extreme on there? Right.
Well we did have several interviews where
the host was a leftist and the other
guest was an extremist Muslim
and they would gang up on me,
give him more time and not giving me
the right of reply or for let's say,
you know you're doing something right
or articles about me without even asking
my opinion or just pops up article one,
article two,
article three.
And so were you shocked once you started
talking about these issues and the
problems that you see within Islam and
the and the solutions that you see?
Were you shocked, were you were
getting comfort from and where are you?
We're getting hatred from?
I always absolutely confused.
Confused is the right word to put it
because on one hand I've got politicians,
me telling me that you are an asset,
you speak English,
you're young, you're presenting
yourself well, you know how to talk.
You're against the extremist.
You love Australia clean record,
we need you but not publicly.
So that really hurt because
what do you mean not publicly?
You want to work with me behind the scene,
but you still want to visit the extremists
for votes. Why wouldn't they want, oh,
so that's purely votes because,
so that really does tell you about some
demographics that does does. So they'll,
they'll sit with me privately and these
meetings aren't official meetings.
It's not enough. I would actually have
my, my turban on the side and we're just,
I'll open some buttons and we just,
it was a very relaxed gathering with
this politics. Should the record,
you walked in here a turban lists her
man and without the robes. So just FYI.
And it was a very uh,
friendly gathering with the gifts.
We would exchange gifts but as soon as
the issue turned public it's like they're
not normally.
So that almost gets to the heart of
exactly why the discussion around Islam is
so difficult because every time someone
tries to come in and talk some sense
about the difference between an ideology
and people and all of the sort of
moderate things that I see you
talking about all the time.
You guys are the ones that
get thrown under the bus.
There's so many examples of this.
I've almost every minority that
tries to fight from within,
they're the ones that get thrown under
the bus and then all that does is
strengthen the extremist.
I think what helped me a lot was the
fact that I had a political adviser and
then who worked in the,
in the Australian parliament for 40 years,
retired now. Uh, Australian.
So born in Australia,
non Muslim, yeah. And can I ask
you his name? Just know. Okay.
I'm really sorry because I
feared for his safety. Okay.
And basically this man was giving me
advice as to how to handle the media
because look, Dave, you asked
me a question about how I felt.
Let me just give you one scenario so you
know exactly what was going through my
mind.
I'm criticizing extremists on Twitter.
I get a phone call from the uh,
ABC in Australia.
This is the, the main Australian
Broadcasting Corporation.
And they asked me what is my opinion about
claims that I am aligning myself with
the right? And I said, what
is the right? I did not know.
So I came from a completely a
conservative Muslim background.
Now I'm trying to serve humanity.
This is my only agenda to so going against
the extremist and someone's telling
me that there's lifting is right now I
have to sit back and try to understand
what's happening. All right?
So which politician that I
met with was on the right,
which one was on the left.
We're trying to put everything
together and get some perspective.
And that was one of the
things that really confused.
So it was really good to have a political
adviser two and a half years ago
because he told me exactly
what was going on. Yeah.
So what about the reaction from
within the community though?
I would imagine once you start
talking about these things,
often the reaction from
within the community is going
to be even worse because
now you're a trader and a
sellout and the rest of it,
the community reaction was very fast and
evaporate quickly because if the mom's
state silence,
if the lead is carried on,
then it would be a different scenario.
So what do you make of that?
I make that the lead is a agree with me
because they still come to my house and
we have dinners and no problem.
But they don't want any photos.
But I do have photos,
but I share that with the
people in government to know
what the progress is with
what I'm doing. I'm not a one man
band who's walking around with nobody.
No Muslim leaders come to my house and
we have amazing dinners and we talk about
Muslim issues,
but the community will reject them if
they know that they have relations with me
in a way that does that type of person.
Although I can sympathize with their
position, right. They don't want it.
They don't want their congregation to
turn on them or something like that.
But that type of person that gives
you the quiet support but won't do it
publicly, isn't an in a way the
most frustrating type of support.
I find that I've also many people that
will come up to me, public people,
people were famous with plenty more money
and all sorts of things that come up
to me and say, David, you know, I really
love your show. And I have, I'm sorry,
I can't tweet about it.
I just don't want to get in hot water
or, or, and I think this is a theme
amongst a lot of the people that,
that were sort of connected
to. Um, it's frustrating,
but I also appreciate it because at least
I know who's on my side and who will
not attack me with a fatwa
without me knowing. So it's good.
I don't appreciate the sign at once.
Is there a co fat,
why could we get a fat while on both
of us? Right? There would be amazing.
It's like an episode of curb your
enthusiasm, but it would be amazing.
But it would certainly paved the way for,
for other people to get fed to us.
So I don't know how we would feel about
that. Right, right. We can deal with it.
We can, we can. Um,
okay.
So let's just do a little bit of sort of
Islam one o one and sort of how to talk
about these issues.
So when I first sort of became
interested in all of this,
most of my audience knows my
sort of political evolution,
but it was the night and I,
I suspect you've probably
seen this, that Sam Harris,
the neuroscientists was on real time with
Bill Maher and they were talking about
the difference between Islam,
a set of ideas and Muslims as people.
And that you shouldn't be prejudice,
but you should be allowed
to criticize ideas.
And the line that sort of
caught the internet on fire
was Ben Aflac Calling Bill
Maher in Sam Harris, gross and racist. He
said, that's gross and racist. And for me,
and I was, that was a progressive at the
time and the whole thing. Um, I thought,
Whoa, this just captures everything
that I've seen wrong with my,
the inability to deal with
a complex issue honestly.
And that the immediate charge is you
must be racist, you must be a bigot.
And the rest of it. So first off, can
you just talk a little bit about that?
Just how you can talk about a doctrine,
any doctrine, but in this case, you know,
through an Islamic Lens and then how,
how you can do that,
but then not be racist or
prejudice towards people.
Okay.
That's a very dangerous area to fall
into because I'm not a political
commentator.
I am trying to change the
mentality of a community,
at least on a local level.
Socially,
I might not be able to change Mecca
and changed the whole religion,
but at least where we live,
we want to have a peaceful community.
So I'm trying to present a better example
for the moderates or the vulnerable
ones, then the extremist
Islam in their own mosque.
So it is a very dangerous field because
the moment you lose their trust,
you lose a Muslim Muslim man's trust
or any Muslim individuals trust.
If you then recite the Quran,
they'll say you're lying because
they lost her trust. It's finished,
they're not trust you anymore.
And I find that very difficult
to get that point across.
However,
what I do is I use a lot of
quotations and so it's not my words.
I quote certain issues and I refer to
certain social events and I comment on
them.
So I try my best not to make any
statements from myself because the,
the level of mentality within
the Muslim world is that, okay,
as long as it has a divine coating,
then we'll accept it.
If it's from he be himself,
then it's manmade.
So if it's divine,
they also can't reject it.
So I tried to use a lot of quotations.
Okay.
So can you give me an example of say a
quotation and then how you would approach
it?
Definitely. For example,
when I speak against stoning,
I can refer to the more
secret book outside the crime,
the Makati and show that this stoning
began when two monkeys were throwing rocks
at each other in Behati
throwing rocks at each other.
And the companion of Mohammed saw them
and said, okay, so that, that must be,
must be a female. I must've cheated
on that mail. So he's stolen, incur.
So we must apply that. And this is
the more sacred book after the Quran.
And the Quran itself does not have a
verse on stolen it because a goat eight of
that verse.
So what I do is I bring to the sacred
scriptures that speak them at stoning how
it began with monkeys.
And it began and the verse that was
supposedly there was eaten by a goat.
And I quickly say, well,
this is a monkey teaching.
It sounds finally as hell. I'm having a
go at them. But the evidence is there.
Yeah. Um, okay. So we can,
we can talk about these issues.
A certain amount of people all over the
map are gonna not be happy with either
one of us.
What do you have,
do you have proof of some of the inroads
that you've been able to make in terms
of d radicalizing people?
The extremists are so frustrated with me.
They're trying to ban the,
I've got diplomats and the Pakistan
government that tried to shut me down.
Uh, are you banned on Facebook
as we tape this right now?
You were band a couple of days ago.
Can you just explain to people what
you posted because I retweeted it.
It's incredible. I didn't,
I wasn't sure if the band,
the band was still awful while I was
cause they hopefully it's still out by the
time we post this in a couple of days,
but hopefully not
the, uh, amazing Song Jihad Bells,
Jihad bells.
Do you handle the way I got that song
and I posted it on Facebook and I said I
share this song every Christmas
because the extremists don't like it.
Therefore please share
it. And it's, it's a,
it's a funny song at ridicules
them for what they're doing.
And Facebook shut me down for 30 days and
said that was hate speech and that was
it.
So I find it very ridiculous.
This is the mind time Facebook
has blocked me or bang,
you're a published my page
completely in 2018 so it's,
you know, the Twitter has
never suspended me. Not once.
Yeah,
nothing.
What do you make of what's going on with
our ability to talk about these issues
online?
So you haven't been suspended by Twitter,
but this has happened a bunch
of times on Facebook. Yes.
Do you know my friend Faisal
Al Mutar chance. So Faisal,
who is one of my best friends on
earth, I love the guy, I adore him.
He has been banned several
times for tweeting out,
similar or for posting on Facebook.
Several things like that. It's like,
did they realize,
do you think they realize they're actually
emboldening the extremists the more
they try to take people like you out?
Well,
they definitely do because the extremist
only operate as much as they do because
they know that they can operate with
no criticism or if there is criticism,
it's only one or two accounts
that are speaking against them.
So by shutting me down,
I mean,
that's a big win for the Jihad.
This because let's not forget jihadist
use Facebook friend recommendations to
build cyber societies,
the cyber caliphate.
And it's a real study that
Facebook's been falling into.
This trap where it's,
it's website recommends Jihad this
to each other based on the pages.
They're like,
yeah.
So now they have this community
and Twitter is the same.
Twitter recommend friends to each other.
So these guys have that advantage
with the help of Facebook and Twitter,
but we don't,
when someone likes my page,
the next person that comes on is a right
wing figure. So the people say, okay,
we're not going to like this page.
I'm going to unfollow this guy
too. Yeah, it's incredible.
You're fighting an ideological war at
some level and a, and an algorithmic war.
Yes. I had another level. So let's
just do some of the definitional stuff.
Um, so first off you, you've
mentioned moderate Muslims sometimes.
So what would you say are the categories,
so to speak of of Muslim
people? Okay, well there's a Muslim who
believes in God, believes in the prophet,
Mohammed's believes in the Quran
and just an average person who,
and this is me speaking in the West,
uh,
believes that they should pray
five times a day fast in Ramadan,
seller based the Muslim celebrations.
That's about it.
That's the definition of a Muslim.
Yeah.
But can you be less than that and
still be Muslim so to speak. So you,
so you couldn't be just sort
of nominally secular Muslim,
where do you don't pray five
times a day or are Muslim by name?
So you would say that.
Would you say that to ex Muslim?
So there is a girl I wanted to ask you
about the ex Muslim community also,
but so you would say that's just,
you would say that's actually not Muslim,
that's just sort of,
look I'm Muslim.
The term Muslim,
it's taken from Islam,
which means submission.
So when it's a verb and Muslim
is a man who submitting,
so you're everyday you're praying so
you are upholding that name of being a
Muslim. If you don't pray
then you just Muslim by name,
you're not an actual Muslim,
you're not an ex Muslim because you
haven't been announced the religion,
you just missing prayers
or drinking alcohol. Right.
So do you have any idea
the number is a bad amount?
I would imagine in the West that that's
probably a very large percentage of
Muslims.
The majority of Muslims believe
in God and uh, and uh, and pray.
And there are also Muslims
that believe in God.
I love believe in Mohammed but don't pray.
Right.
So I wouldn't say that's an issue for us.
They can pray or not pray whenever they,
like for me it's the more extremist
ones and then trying to differentiate
between the moderate and the extreme.
Right. Okay. So we've got sort
of just the ones by name only.
I gather the ones who let's say
aren't practicing but, but still are,
they were born Muslim.
There was,
and then the ones who are not practicing
on the ones the WISC refers to as
moderates.
Right.
So that's where I was trying to get with
this to understand what your definition
of moderate is.
Yeah.
It's the ones who don't practice.
And by not practicing,
I mean the other laws of
Islam. So for example, the uh,
the stoning of the killing,
the reporting on people who break the
blasphemy law issues like the people who
just don't care.
I just want to go to work nine to five,
come back and raise a family, you
know, live life, go on holidays. Yeah.
Parents were Muslim. We born
Muslim, but that's about it.
These guys are the ones who
are referred to as moderates,
but they're not really moderates.
The moderate is the,
the ex, the, the, the,
the Muslim that is conservative
but wishes to ban certain,
uh, teaching, setting verdicts.
They are the moderates.
So the moderate is the one who sort of
staying within the religion and fighting
the extreme parts of the religion
personally on a family level, not raising
their children in extremist mosques.
Those on the mothers.
Okay. And then you obviously
include yourself in that.
Well, uh, well I can see why this
would be a tough question for them.
I don't believe in something called the
mother Islam now just for the viewers
don't get confused.
Yeah,
I'm answering your question based on
what society and what Islam Sates.
My personal opinion
could be another thing.
So you might want to ask me what
my opinion is on this issue.
I don't believe there's a mother of,
let's pretend I asked you your opinion.
There is no mother Islam.
Islam is Islam and uh,
you're either a reformist I reformer
or reformed person or you're still on
Muslim.
The Muslims were doing to chop the
handle of the fee if and don't stolen and
don't, uh, you know, applying
the violence of Sharia law there,
they've diverted away from
the core beliefs of Islam.
So in a weird way,
you're an e mom who also,
you obviously have a great,
affinity is not the right word.
You have a great respect,
I suppose for the,
for the ex Muslims in a way,
the extra Muslims have every
right to be where they are.
Yeah.
Because now is the west top to be a Muslim
and when I'm Muslim has a problem or
is facing a problem, whether it
be inheritance, financial issues,
abuse at home, divorced after
being married off. You know,
at a very young age they don't find
the person who listens to them.
The majority of moms in mosques have
zero qualifications when it comes to
counseling. When it comes to
solving real life problems,
they only know how to talk
when it's against Israel,
against the Jews and to play the victim
card and basically spread news about
what they're doing in society.
So the ex Muslims,
the majority of them leave the
religion because number one,
they really feel it's
not for them anymore.
And the people who paved
the way for them. Uh, right.
I do know that some people read Richard
Dawkins or read certain books and then
changed their religion or
leave religion completely.
But Isis makes more ex Muslims
than any intellectual in the West.
So to, if we want to blame
x Muslim for me ex Muslim,
it's the Muslim, the fundamentalist
Muslims that made them ex Muslim.
They are the ones who are
making them leave the religion
and that's completely contrary to what
the media would portray about this.
They would say it's,
it's that if you talk about any of this,
you're driving people to become
extremists, which as many people call it,
this is the soft bigotry
of low expectations.
If I was to say anything
that might offend you,
you would automatically
become an extremist,
which is such a horrific way of viewing
a, another human being. You know,
is there something that I could say to
you that somehow you might end up blowing
me up? Nothing. If you were to
kill me and I'll come back to low,
I'd still have,
I still shake your head or you got
another to worry about brother. Um, okay.
So let, let's just do a little bit
more of, of the deaf. Okay. So wait,
so we have sort of the ex Muslims
and the nominal Muslim then,
then the moderate that you say
is not really a thing actually.
Then can you sort of explain, uh,
Islamists and jihadists. Okay.
And if there's anything else
that I missed within that
Islamist is an individual that believes
in preaching and spreading and expanding
Islam and the message of
Islam through militant means.
So there would spread Islam by the
sword and now the tactics are a bit
different.
Now it's getting through congress.
So before it was by the sword,
now it's getting themselves
into parliament and then
making laws that act as the
sword, the Islamophobia law in
Canada and one or three. Yeah.
So an Islamist would silence
you just to spread his agenda.
That's different from a Muslim,
I'm Muslim would say, okay,
this is the Koran I
believe is the right God.
I believe Islam is true except
that you don't accept it.
You're not going to be
saved. Goodnight. Goodnight.
That's basically a Muslim and Islam
most will actually go the extra mile of
kidnapping someone because they drank
alcohol a whipping them because they
believe that is the right thing to do.
We've seen across Europe,
statues are being destroyed
because it's not allowed in Islam.
So that's an Islamist and Islamist
organization would be Hamas.
Hamas is an Islamist organization
that did terrorist. Uh, doings,
it's responsible for terrorist activities.
So then it became a
terrorist organization.
But its ideology is an Islamist ideology.
So two state solution is not an option.
They need to be eliminated because
our message is the right one.
That's an Islamist mentality.
Now the other person or the other group
of people would be the fundamentalists,
a fundamentalist Muslim once to preserve
the message of Prophet Mohammed and
live like Mohammed the same way he lived.
So if the report,
say Mohammad had a short pants because
his pants would stop to his ankle,
they'd go to the university,
Harvard University and with
their ankles sticking out.
So if there was no deodorant in Macau,
we're not going to use the order.
And if they, if Mohammad never
trimmed his beard with a blade,
then we're not going to use a blade
on ours. That's a fundamentalist.
And these guys will always take the
side of the Islamist rather than the
moderate. And also moderate it
just a politically created term.
It's a political term to differentiate.
But at the end of the day,
I don't believe there's one that you in
the Muslim iron arts and then there are
liberals in faith as
to how deep you on how,
how much into the religion you are.
So where does the jihadist fit into that?
Because I thought that was a little bit
of your definition of a Islamist because
of the,
because of the use of violence,
the Islamist isn't always a jihadist.
Islam is,
can be someone who believes in the
ideology of spreading Islam by violence,
who believes that's the right way,
that's how religion should develop.
But they don't actually go and fight.
You know who these people are?
The majority of the moms,
so they're sitting in their mosques
recruiting, sending people to Isis,
but they're not jihadists that in Momma's
responsible for the jihadist growing
and fun joining Isis.
So here's the Islamist
and he would send the,
the Islamist congregation
to them become jihadists.
So this is when,
when people talk about the radicalization
that's happening in mosques in the
West,
you believe that to be a real thing.
Of course it is a real thing and it's
something we battle every single day.
What? So what if I was to
go into one of these marks,
what would I be hearing? Well,
firstly, because of your beard,
you'd be welcome to lengthen this a
little bit. Okay. So you'd be welcome.
Okay.
And a fundamentalist mosque would there
would definitely frown upon you if you
had shaved opiate completely.
So be it.
You'd be welcome to have you don't have
a beard. You actually can't even go in.
No, I don't care. They'll just tell
you why. What's wrong? Are you a woman?
Are you a Jew?
Why?
Because the reports saying that the
Jews that came to fight Mohammed had no
beard design. It was a sign
of going to war and in Arabia,
the sign of going toward
would be to shave your head.
The Jews in Arabia would
shave their beards.
So then you can tell who is who
in the backdrop. So Jesus, yes,
slums kept their beards. Okay,
so it's not a credit. I mean,
there are many reformers were don't
have beer. It's not a big deal.
I grow this out. It's a week from
now. I say to you, let's get mom,
get me to one of these masks. I want to
know what's going on. I walk in with you,
let's say on a Friday prayer. Yeah,
we're just tell me what, what,
what is actually being spoke of that
is the place from where it goes from in
Islam as an ideology to a fundamentalist
ideology? Well, what are people hearing?
Well firstly it depends on the speaker.
It depends on the MRI.
There are Islamist in moms who say in
close circles what they will not say on
the pulpits because of
the laws in the West.
And then there are in moms who would go
on there and things nobody could have
imagined would ever be set and the
history of Islam on the pulpit,
they will just say it.
So there
between the West and some of them,
they're doing this in though.
I mean we see this out of Canada a lot,
just these incredibly,
I'm awful things that
people that they're saying
memory has a wonderful archive
of all of these issues.
Youtube is another great source.
And the issue is they,
the Mascaro records that your mom
and applauds it on. You've chipped.
So it's nothing being discovered.
They,
they know that the world is going to
react this way and they still continue to
produce this content and now
they're speaking in English,
which makes my job a lot easier because
I have to translate sometimes but now
they were just saying it in English.
Yes we want to be heard
and we want to conquer. And
so when they're,
when I see these videos and memory does
a great job of the translations when I
see these videos,
but let's say the new ones that aren't
translated from Canada for example,
they want that message
to get out of the mosque.
Like you would think that's
contrary to what they would want.
You'd think it's like you'd want to keep
it sort of radicalized within so you
can put a good face on things.
But you're saying when they're talking
about this and now with the Jews and the
gays and this and that and the other
thing you think they actually want that to
get out there?
Cause they're the ones putting it out.
Yes.
And also there's a concept of the one
Muslim nation and it's called the Muslim
Ummah Islam,
the Islamic nation.
Now what it is is basically a Muslim
is a citizen of two or more nations.
One of the nation, they live in America,
Australia,
the UK,
and the second one is the nation of Islam.
Not Farrakhan,
but the actual Islamic nation.
So if the mufti in Mecca issues affect
Wa and Islam are sitting in La would come
in a terrorist attack. You
see that connection? Yeah.
So when they were Salman
Rushdie's at Starbucks,
yes you're on issues or
fatwah they'll get him here.
There's a link and no other religion has
this power unless it's an organized a
organization that targets
people in sense Hitman,
but no other religion has this power.
And in mom in Mecca would would say
that the Jews are the enemy or that the
Christians are the enemy.
Knowing 100% that they will be a Muslim
who would go and comment a terrorist
attack. He doesn't even have to look
for him and doesn't need to do anything.
He just knows the Muslim who will
get this and we'll do the job.
Not other religion has this.
And we see it several times where the,
in Russia they killed the a uh,
I think it was a, sorry, in Turkey,
I think it was a Russian ambassador
was shot dead. Oh yeah, yeah,
there's video of it. Yeah. Just
right in the fight in the museum.
There's nothing that was supposed to
protect him. And he said for Syria,
and we see us every single month and
act doesn't go by without in the west,
committing a terrorist attack and saying,
this is for Syria, this is for Iraq.
What's that link? And this confuses
our intelligence departments.
They've never seen anything like it.
So when we're speaking about the
moms uploading videos online,
they're actually contributing to
that platform of the Islamic nation.
Whoever's out there.
This is our message.
So I know you a free speech guy because
I see you tweeting about it all the time
and then you're exercising. You are free
speech here. It's a beautiful thing.
What should be done now? I
don't mean just from, you know,
the inside conversation, say you
meeting with a a more fundamentalist,
the mom and trying to, you
know, uh, get him back,
let's say towards the center or something.
But what should be done by these states?
What should Canada,
what should the United States,
what should Australia be doing
because they're using the,
the freedoms of the West
against themselves. I mean,
this is as difficult to free
speech topic as there is for the,
for the true free speech people.
Yep.
They're fighting for democratic rights
to be applied for the extremist,
for the Islamist when their Islam is,
doesn't believe in democracy.
They will use democracy to destroy
democracy and then establish their on a
belief system. Now what
can we do? I think,
and I say this all the time when,
when I'm having dinner with a politician
or a premiere or you know, and I say,
your political party is finished. You
guys are infiltrated. And if you email me,
I'll send you reports about one or
two of your candidates and what their
backgrounds are like.
And they remained spit just,
and I'm not speaking in Liberal,
I'm speaking Conservative Party.
I'm speaking parties who, you
know, we have hope in. Okay.
These guys will seriously serve,
uh,
the cause of national security will
tighten the situation at the borders more
than let these jihad this come in, uh,
refugees who ended up being behind this,
that we've had them in Australia.
So these guys are being infiltrated.
So number one,
what we can.
So what does that mean?
They're being infiltrated?
Meaning meaning that there are actual
operatives within the political parties.
I mean,
I just had Brigitte Gabriel on who talks
a lot about the Muslim Brotherhood's
long plan that this is an actual plan.
Yes.
It's,
it's one of the main plans to infiltrate
political parties and then make their
way into positions where they
can change or make the law.
And we've seen this numerous
times. I mean, my book,
I speak about a lady deep,
I mean, uh, she became,
well she's deceased now,
she passed away,
but she wa she actually said that about
her long term goal is to make all of
American Muslim and she was getting
grants from the American government.
She was overseeing educational curriculums
and, and you see this, I mean
even in the United States,
and I'm not totally sure this is her
name, Alon Omar, is that her name?
The representative in Minnesota
who just got elected and you know,
should they found old tweets of hers
where she's saying, you know, uh,
the Jews or Israel has pulled the wool
over something and all ask to take care
of this. And then the entire time that
she was being elected, she kept saying,
she's against boycotting Israel. The day
she gets elected and now she's for it.
So, so this is not just pie in the
sky stuff that you're talking about.
Everything you see in the Muslim world
when it comes to politics is all studied,
is strategic. It's all planned,
well funded, well organized,
and they know exactly what to do.
And when to do it.
All the media that's going
on now against the, uh,
the organizations such as care,
they do no harm to care whatsoever.
Care has a clear vision and they are
reaching their goals because there are
loopholes and there are cracks within
the system and they're equivalent in
Canada. They're equivalent in
Australia. And these, you know,
these loopholes within the government
keep getting bigger and bigger as these
guys get elected.
And I don't want to scare your viewers,
but all I have to say is these
people are very smart people.
They're not what the media says that
when they actually attack and then there
are mentally ill or these people are,
are minorities,
they're very strategic and they're very,
very smart,
which is why intelligence services around
the world need hundreds of millions of
dollars just to keep up with
what these guys are doing,
that we need these resources to
understand how they operate and they keep
learning and they're getting better
and better. What do you make of
the, uh, the progressive
alliance seemingly with Islamist?
I, I, to me, this is like
the biggest piece of this,
that you've got certain pieces,
pieces of the left that are just useless
idiots basically are, they're useful,
idiot,
not useless.
They're useful because they're allowing
these people to attain power in the name
of tolerance. And it's like, well,
you guys will just be the last
ones to be beheaded. I mean,
that's really the way I
see this thing playing out.
First,
when I was in a fundamentalist Islamist,
someone who rejected the West
rejected ballot with the West,
my best friends from the outside world,
you know, and I wouldn't say there were
friends who aren't your personally,
but the people who I
considered our friends,
our allies where the leftists.
So when I was a fundamentalist
in mom's sitting in,
in Iraq or Iran,
and I am on social media,
there were certain people,
I liked politicians.
I liked Jeremy Corbyn hero.
Uh, people like that. Yeah.
Hillary Clinton,
every Muslim,
every extremist Muslim in the United
States votes for Hillary Clinton.
This is a fact. I'm not saying all of
them volts, but lords will do four vote.
Hillary. There would
never republican. Right.
So can you explain that connection
there? There's a common agenda. The edge.
It's very common. I mean you take a
look at what these guys are doing.
It's very common. Most extremist
Muslims just want to operate.
Who's going to give them that free room
to breathe. They'll vote for that person.
And Hillary and Obama, these
guys, they funded Isis,
they funded isis and they funded
and with Jackie Dean, the jihadists,
these rebels who killed my
family and these guys fund them.
So the extremist at the end of the day,
it's not seen as a threat by the
Democratic Party and they visit them every
Ramadan and they sit with them
every Ramadan and they, you know,
they welcome each other.
So what do you think, okay,
so I'll go with you on that.
But what do you think then is in the
mind of Hillary or Obama or any of these
other lower level politicians that then
I would say again are useful idiots
basically.
They don't understand the threat that
you're laying out here are or do they,
are they in that?
Like what?
What do you think is actually going
on in the mind of Hillary when,
when she's doing these things,
and we don't even have to make
it about her specifically,
but any of these people,
she understands the threat and
so do many people like her.
They know the threat
of what they're doing.
I think they're just greedy because
they know they can't be touched,
so she's protected. She doesn't
care about anybody else. It's greed,
but pat protection doesn't always last.
Right. I mean this, this is a fool's game,
right?
It doesn't last,
but I mean,
I think she's going to teach
for the rest of her life.
She's going to have that protection
at least because you know, any Iraq,
we had the same situation.
How did isis get in?
Ice has gone into Iraq because certain
politicians plate the diversity game.
You know, why have borders with
Saudi Arabia? Why have a wall,
let the desert to be open and then these
cars came in from around the world and
they took over 40 minutes
away from bad debt.
I mean then politicians, when their
family members were being killed,
they will up. So maybe that,
that's what it takes, that you,
you experience the threat
of jihad personally.
Then you'll understand where in Mankato
Hillary is coming from and people like
Dave Rubin who understand what your mom
told he is saying maybe some people will
wake up, but then again, that's
another world of politics.
Let's talk about immigration a little
bit cause it's been sort of a thread
through this. Um, your first
strong border protection,
uh, I mentioned to you
right before we started,
I was in London a couple months ago and
I hadn't been there for quite some time
before that. I've been there twice this
year and the first time I was there,
one of the things that was shocking to me,
it's just,
it's just viscerally shocking and it has
nothing to do with bigotry or hatred or
anything else is that I was in,
you know,
the Harrods area right in the sort of
center of London and the amount of women
that I saw in burqas. I mean
only eyes. That's it. Now,
I have no problem with those
people individually of course,
but seeing this amount,
I mean I'm talking,
it seemed like at points 20 or
30% of the women now, if they, if,
if I had seen 30% of the women dressed
in traditional Mormon clothing or dressed
as orthodox Jews,
I would have also thought there's
something strange going on here.
Let's put it that way.
That's what I do.
It's just like this
something odd going on here.
Can you just talk about that related to
Western countries and then how that's
related to immigration?
Very simple.
You see how I had to even ask the
question in a way that's like,
I'm apologizing for seeing something.
It's like it's pathetic.
Yeah. Uh, it's very simple. The West
has become weaker. They become stronger.
They're telling you this is the norm.
In fact, this is the college norm.
This is how we're going to address.
You're going to look at us and you're
going to turn away if you're not like it.
That's basically it. That's
what's happening now. Are
these people extremists?
Of course.
I'm not saying every lady that
always a burger is an extremist.
What I'm saying is because you
know this is between us on camera.
Yeah, don't worry, it's just
going to youtube. So you know,
some of the filthiest woman to ever
exist are ones that were burgers,
seriously hookers.
Uh,
they were brokers because they don't
want them their faces to be not. And uh,
you know, now in Baghdad from the
reports that come, because you know,
I speak to officials,
they tell us that they have a problem
with prostitution and the woman are
wearing burgers and they want to stand
out from the other women that are wearing
burkas. So what they do is they flip their
attire inside out, but it's all black.
But all you have to do is focus on
that thread. Is that inside out?
Ah, so an inside out
burger and fries to three,
exactly in Baghdad and some air,
some Muslim areas.
If a lady went in there with a burger,
they know she's up to something.
So this isn't Islamophobia,
this is Muslim areas or what's,
what's she up to? So
it's none of that. Oh,
I wear it to preserve my modesty.
No one's going to hit on me or on the
street and cat calling. No. In fact,
some guys got there just to look for these
women because they know she's out for
business. Yeah. No, not all of them,
but this does exist for the women
who live in the West who web workers.
There are several types of women.
One,
one that's forced by her husband.
The second one,
the second type is the type that would
divorce her husband if he told her to
take it off and the third one would be
someone who is just trying to fit in with
all of this.
We are the rebels in society.
We are the real Muslims.
That's basically my analysis of the city.
Yeah.
Do the average leftie that used to be
your ally when you were more extreme,
so to speak,
do you think they realize that this set
of ideas is so in direct conflict with
the rest of their ideas, their
rest of their ideas, tolerance,
and we're for gays and minorities and
women and all of these things that they've
aligned themselves with
it with an ideology.
If you were to look at
it in their pyramid,
they've put Islam really at the top of
their pyramid because they believe it's a
brown person's religion,
which of course is is a racist notion
in itself because a religion is not of a
skin color.
Um,
but do you think they even realize
like now I'm not talking about say the
Islamist, what they realize their
alliance is the other way around.
Do you think these people have
any sense of what's going on here?
I think what's happening now is that
loyalty has shifted from being loyal to
your country and to your people, to being
loyal to your boss and to your company.
So I've seen generalists who would
write wonderful articles about me.
The moment they get a job
and a left leaning outlets,
it's like I'm a whore. I'm the worst
person that they've ever known.
And the contradiction remains
online. Like what happened here? I'm,
I'm someone who is going to influence
the Australia and I'm a peaceful guy and
they welcome me and here I am
a fraud who should be silenced.
Don't give him the megaphone. So you
see, I think a loyalty falls in, uh,
companies, uh, no more in,
in country or faith or family.
Yeah.
Can you talk a little bit about the sort
of unique way that Islam is designed to
spread?
So already,
are you familiar with Dr Bill
Warner who does political islam.com?
So one of the things that
he said when I had him on,
I think this is probably over three years
ago, that I thought it was interesting.
He said that religions are
designed to spread differently.
So Judaism for example,
it's very hard to convert.
You have to do a lot to convert.
But if you want to get out,
you just basically say, I'm not a
Jew. Every Jew would be like, ah,
you're still a Jew. And then that's it.
Where Islam, it's very easy to get in,
right?
You just have to recite something very
quickly and it's almost impossible to get
out because then you're an apostate,
so now we can, we can kill you.
So he said it's actually a virus is,
is very easy to attain and
very difficult to eliminate.
So that's what he was comparing it to.
I thought it was an interesting analogy.
Okay. Um, for me personally,
the way I see it is if Islam was going
to grow in Huston row in the right
direction,
because I believe Muslims will always
be converting people and there'll be,
people always come back to Islam.
So I don't believe religion can be
stopped at all or eliminated. I mean,
look at Judaism,
they never had a government to protect
them for thousands and thousands of years.
Everyone was trying to kill
them and did in fact kill them.
They've been butchered in the millions,
but they still, they're still around.
It's hard. It's not hard. It's almost
impossible to eradicate a religion.
It doesn't work like that. Uh,
so that's my take my position.
So I don't see it as a virus.
I just believe people will always have
certain opinions and and change religions.
What I do acknowledge is the fact that
Islam is very strategic in recruiting
adherence to its belief system.
And this isn't all Islamic schools
of thought, but the majority of them,
so the majority of mainstream do actually
have a strategy and it's called throw
down that way.
What does it is they go out to the
streets and there are basically selling
religion. There was solid religion
and in return they'll give you heaven,
a paradise in the hereafter.
That's the basic transaction.
And you know there's an
audience for everything.
This is a fact and many people do embrace
Islam because of the promises that
they get.
I mean if you're a businessman and
you're stopped by one of these stalls and
they'll tell you there's so much
wealth waiting for you, one prayer,
we'll build your five castles.
If you're a farmer, they'll tell,
they'll promise you massive farms in,
in paradise.
If they know that you're like women,
they'll promise you plenty of women.
Like the Jihad is 72 virgin issue. Let's
see. Two virgins seems like a bit much.
No,
the actual teaching say each one of
these 72 virgins comes with her aids.
So it's actually more than 72.
And the actual number 72 or 70 in
the Arabic language just means a lot.
It means unlimited PTO is right.
I've told you a million times.
That's good to know. So
it's not actually 72. Um,
and it's not raisins either.
Maybe people say it's not because the
Islamic books describe their hair,
their eyes. And if one hair
wants to fall on planet earth,
the perfume would be smarter by everyone.
So there are descriptions that
these actual women non reasons.
So the strategy of Islam spreading is
very unique in a sense that their unity,
uh, in, in their urology is
unbreakable. It's impossible. I mean,
I'm Muslim would unite with a Muslim,
against a Christian, against an atheist,
even if he knows his brother and faith
is wrong. So then how are you a Muslim?
And that's the thing. When you ask him,
are Shia Muslims Muslim? They'll say, no,
you asked the Shia and the Sunni
Muslim, they'll say, not real Muslims.
Then that Hamodia will say,
both of these guys are not Muslim.
I'm the real Muslim.
And then bought the she and the suddenly
all the United against that at the and
say, here's what the real Muslim, so
it's a struggle within Islam itself.
It's a problem. And they fall into
many contradictions because of this,
because Muslims killing Muslims everyday
Muslim governments bombing all Muslim
governments,
right? I mean what's going on with Saudi
Arabia in Yemen, right? Yeah, yeah.
Which nobody talks about of course,
because we don't know
how to frame it properly.
So we just wait for something
to happen with Israel basically.
And then it's like, oh well now we can,
we got good guys and bad guys. It's easy.
So all right. So two more questions
for you. So one, where do you,
what do you think it is about you?
About the guy I'm sitting across from
him right now that gives you the sort of
bravery to talk about
this. This is, this is,
I mean that's why when first came
on the scene and everyone was like,
talk to this guy, I was hesitant
because I was like, I just,
I just don't know enough that I had a,
I don't want the wool pulled over my eyes,
but be, you know, as your critics will
say, there's fame to gain out of this.
There is all of this other,
a bounty to be habit.
So what is it about you
that makes you do this?
I'm nobody special.
I swear I'm nobody special.
I'm just a regular guy who
grew up in almost a family,
was trained in Iran,
um,
life put me in this position
or they end as a scholar,
came back to Australia,
started meeting with politicians.
It worked out really well.
More politicians started inviting me.
We started working with parliaments,
advising senates,
and I have a Twitter
account that I'm active on.
I have a foundation and organization,
basic stuff.
And I speak out only because I've always
been outspoken about it when I was in
Islam as I was an outspoken Islam.
So let's put it that way.
Going out smoking Islam. This sound like
you don't want to hear it. It's horrible.
I was outspoken.
I used to flagellate.
I don't know if you've seen
my pictures now, but you,
so you actually used to do it. Yeah.
Wait, can you explain what that is?
I would cover myself in my own blood.
Absolute flagellation so you know I'm,
I'm,
I'm not a convert into the religion.
I've come from that whole lineage
and lifestyle. You got credit,
but people usually ask me what red
pilled you and because this is politics,
this is religion.
I just don't know how to answer that.
But I think the best way to put it is
that I have always been outspoken and I'm
not afraid.
In fact,
I am afraid of the fact that I'm not
afraid because I can get myself into
serious trouble.
I've said certain things in front of
certain people that I've had to leave the
country at the same afternoon.
Yeah. Well your, your Twitter, Twitter,
bio used to be something to the,
do you know what exactly it is?
Where I want to today.
One day you will hear that.
I have been killed and the
news will speak about it.
That was my first Twitter bio and then
I changed it simply because I had a
meeting with state intelligence
and they said, you know what,
you could be giving ideas to
certain people, so remove it.
So I put peace advocate, things like
that. But I do have a, you know,
a great security team and
I'm very grateful for.
Yeah. All right. So my
last question is this.
Paint me two roads of the future. Give
me two pictures of the future, Hawaii,
the the future that you want to
build and then I want the future.
If that does not get built,
what does that look like?
So you can do either one first.
The future, I want to focuses
on the west and the West alone.
The Middle East isn't in my area anymore
because me having this interview,
something like this in the Middle East
would see me killed the same week.
So the best way to reach the Middle
East is through social media.
And I've got my accounts and Arabic,
I've got a counseling,
different languages where I have
translators that do that for me.
But my main vision and my effort and
energy goes into the west and I would like
to see all Islamist
extremist centers shut down.
Uh, the people who are fundamentalists
and have been sponsored by terrorist
organizations such as care to lose
their positions in government.
I would like to see a honorable leader
of a country that cracks down on these
extremists.
On the other hand,
I would like to see the so
called moderates or just
the regular Muslims speaking
out more and they're in moms being more
vocal against the extremists and have
this unity as a society.
You could be Jewish,
I could be Muslim,
our friend could be Christian and we
could just sit down and have a meal
together, shake hands, go
to, you know, a, a match,
watch a match together.
Watch a movie.
No problem in that which people are
doing every day in the west. Yes.
We shouldn't forget that we are
doing that. So after this interview,
I'll go back to Australia and I
go back into the Muslim community.
I don't go back to meeting
with Jews and Christians.
I do that in my interfaith work,
but I actually live amongst
the Muslim community.
So I would like to see that
Muslim community embracing
the larger community in
the West.
That's uh,
my vision because then we can work on
establishing peace and building a better
relations and basically uniting with w
with the rest of the world against the
extremists, within our own
religion. That's my vision.
If that doesn't work out,
I was going to say we should have done
this and the other way because now you're
going to end up ending on,
on the bad notes.
So I'll try to figure out a way to
get us the thumbnail offending is.
If that doesn't work out,
then I believe we have to unite as a,
because there will always be
Muslims or have conservative views.
Do you know how many Muslims
about for Trump? Many.
They flit from the rulers who
Trump is now putting in line.
So they would vote for Trump just for
that very reason that they know that
they're all as back home can start war
with other countries who are allies with
America. So many Muslims
vote for Trump. Well that,
that also is the ultimate irony of the
alliance with the left because it's like
you're taking a group of people
who are inherently conservative,
who old conservative religious values
and then your aligning them with people
that hold none of those values and
they're going, please join us for now.
I think if my vision of the West
doesn't end up being successful,
then we need to unite as the,
uh,
the revisionists reformist Muslims who
are completely against what's happening
unite with the Jews,
with the Christians.
Let's put far left far right aside
and let's just speak as humans who are
concerned about national security,
we need to unite on a professional level.
It's not enough to speak on youtube and,
and to tweet. This isn't enough for me,
which is why I go and I sit
with politicians because
I want to get something
done. So we need tonight,
either now or unite in, in a,
in a much more global style in the
future to end on a positive note.
I'll tell you this,
the Islamists are worried now may be not
showing it too much because they were
getting people into Congress
and people into parliaments,
but then are worried they've
lost a lot of territory.
The caliphate that they dreamed of, they
have lost Isis and they've lost a lot.
I mean the United Arab Emirates
shutting them down, uh,
Austria shut down 60 deported
60 months back to Turkey.
I mean we are doing things
that harm them and harm their,
you know, their, their
agenda of death basically.
And we're doing them in large portion,
so in portions they can't accept 16 months
vanished from the country in one day.
That's a big loss for them.
Yeah. So we are pushing back,
I believe as a,
as a society or as a global
society against the extremists. Uh,
but I think it's a slow way
to the finishing point and
we will win at the end of
the day.
I do know that eventually people will
just get fed up with the extremists and
unite with these reformers and
just get them out of the society.
I don't know how. Maybe in a
hundred years, I don't know,
but it's going to be really bad.
The way we win. We'll be really bad.
That one might be peaceful and it's,
I really hope that we can pave the
way for a much more peaceful ending,
but I'll just say this. Every time
I came on Australian television,
I have a police officer that time
that tells me, you're not your mom.
I've been testing this every
time you go out there speaking,
we get more applications for firearms
because they believe Marine invasion is
coming. So then I started to
tone it down a little bit. Yeah,
but I still want to say
the truth and I wish for
a peaceful ending.
That's basically it.
Isn't it weird how you just have to
live your life and do what you think is
right at all times?
I remember when I first started talking
about this stuff and I was just a little
worried about security and things. I
said to, do you know Dennis Prager? Yes.
I said to Dennis Prager. I asked him
about just security cause it just,
any of any of my friends in this world,
they're talking about this stuff.
I was just asking and I said
to Dennis, uh, you know,
what do you do about security? And he
told me some things that I can't repeat,
but then he goes, but at the end of
the day when it's your time to go,
it's your time to go. I thought,
well, I'm a little younger than you.
I'm not quite ready for that yet. Well
listen, you have an ally in me and I hope,
I hope,
I hope we,
I hope we helped spread a little bit of
what I know you've made your life about.
And uh,
you know,
hopefully there's a way that it doesn't
get that bad before it gets better.
I suppose. We shall see. Definitely.
Thank you so much for having me. Yeah.
And I'm sorry we can't hang out
tonight cause I would've loved to,
but I'm a little crazy at the moment.
And for more on a mom to Iti,
follow him on Twitter before
he's banned at eamomm of peace.